als ob man alle gedacht sei wenn jeder
an sich denkt das war sicherlich einer
der stärksten reden wenn der
eindrücklichsten reden die
bundespräsident steinmeier in den
letzten jahren gehalten hat er hat eine
weltordnung zitiert die in unordnung ist
die unübersichtlich ist die der stern
säulen erodieren und haben zusammen
klappen sind unsicherheit
unberechenbarkeit konfrontation verlust
von vertrauen sind die folge das war
eine sehr eindrückliche rede die
sicherlich nicht in jeder phase der
bundesregierung gefallen wird hier vor
allen anderen die deutschen insgesamt
gerichtet ist wir müssen uns mehr mit
der welt befassen ohne hochmütig und
ohne selbstgefällig zu sagen wir müssen
uns mit dieser welt auseinandersetzen
und sie müssen um unsere interessen in
dieser welt zu wahren und zu fördern uns
für internationale ordnung einsetzen
aber vor allem für das geeinte europa es
handlungsfähiger machen stabil zu machen
damit wir uns in der welt des 21
jahrhunderts was unsere sicherheit
anbelangt und unser wohlstand anbelangt
behaupten können